So, in summary, I'd like to say just a little
bit more about correcting data. The types of corrections that
we typically make to any data set that we're cleaning,
usually involve one or more of the following. We're going
to be removing typographical errors, or correcting them. There will
often be a component in cleaning where we're validating against
a known list of entities. We will frequently be cross
checking our data with a validated data set of some kind.
We might be doing data enhancement, and frequently
are, where we're making data a little more complete
by adding some related information. So for example, we
might have a username, an email address, and first
and last name for every entry in a
record set. And as part of our cleaning process
or part of our process before, we analyze data.
We're going to integrate each of those records with
marketing data for each person on employer and
job title et cetera. Another common thing we do
in cleaning data is harmonizing the data. So for
example in this case, we would be transforming all
abbreviations for street and road to say for
example, their full names, or vise versa. Maybe we're
going the other direction. Likewise with directions. N and
W become north and west, et cetera in addresses.
We might also be changing our data set so
that it uses a new standard for some set of
codes that it contains. So for example, we might
be transforming our data set to, instead of two-digit country
codes, use three-digit codes by simply mapping each of
the two-digit codes onto the appropriate three-digit codes. These are
some of the common types of tasks that we
do when cleaning data, and again, it's very situation specific.
So what we've tried to do throughout this lesson, and what we're going to do
in the problem set, is give you
examples from a few different situations, to give
you some practice with cleaning, so that
you have some concrete examples in mind, when
you get into your own data wrangling tasks
where you need to do some data cleaning.